kennen sie alle die impfgegner ja ich
kenne sie leider sehr gut
ich persönliche zuschriften nicht sehr
viel
auch sehr sehr es erfüllte kommentare
auf facebook schreiben die ihn ja wird
meine position mit der position im
dritten reich verbunden und es wird
gesagt dass es genau wie nach im dritten
reich der nürnberger prozesse für leute
wie mich geben wird
ich bin darüber sehr betroffen wer
traurig weil ich glaube wir sehen uns
doch nach freiheit
und die impfung ist die lösung und haben
sie angst vor diesen ganzen recht
militanten bedrohlichen impfgegnern ja
ich mache mir schon gedanken aber ich
bin gewählte abgeordnete und ich bin
höher die menschen verantwortlich die
mich gewählt haben und ich darf jetzt
nicht die wahrheit einfach nicht
aussprechen
weil ich persönlich angst habe also das
wäre feige
ich bin nach überzeugter christ und ich
glaube daran dass man das richtige tun
muss
selbst wenn man persönlich bedroht wird
und deswegen werde ich für die impfung